the universe looks like a vast empty
ocean sprinkled with rare islands of
galaxies
but this is an illusion
just a small fraction of all atoms are
found in galaxies while the rest is
thought to be drifting in between in The
Intergalactic medium
like the roots of some massive tree gas
spreads out from each Galaxy gravity
funneling fresh Mass into this dense
Cosmic Forest here in The Intergalactic
medium are the raw materials of creation
hydrogen and helium woven into sheets
and filaments that flow into galaxies
where they eventually create Stars
but if we look closely we see who's
actually in charge quasars the single
most powerful objects in existence as
small as a grain of sand compared to the
Amazon River they reside in the centers
of some galaxies shining with the power
of a trillion Stars blasting out huge
Jets of matter completely reshaping the
cosmos around them they're so powerful
that they can kill a Galaxy
what are they and how do they mold the
structure of the universe at their whim
[Music]
everywhere you look weird things in the
sky
in the 1950s astronomers noticed
mysterious loud radio waves coming from
spots all over the sky they were named
quasi-stellar radio sources or quasars
because they were dots like stars but
were seen in radio waves rather than
visible light
everything about them was strange some
flickered others emitted high energy
x-rays in addition to radio waves but
all seemed to be tiny they all moved
extremely fast as much as over 30
percent the speed of light the only
explanation was that they must have been
so distant that their apparent speed was
actually the expansion of the universe
moving them away from us but these
enormous distances meant that quasars
couldn't just be stars but the active
cores of galaxies billions of light
years away and it gets crazier to appear
so bright and Loud given these vast
distances they are thousands of times
brighter than the entire Milky Way
monsters exploding and screaming into
the void were the violence not thought
possible before
as we match the sky we discovered over a
million quasars and they all seem to be
very far away
looking into space far away means very
long ago because light takes so long to
reach us quasars were common in the
early Universe having peaked in number
10 billion years ago when galaxies and
the universe itself were still very
young
let's go back in time just three billion
years after the big bang and see what
was going on back then
the incredible power of quasars
How could an early baby Galaxy be so
incredibly bright and violent all that
light and radiation couldn't be stars as
there weren't nearly enough of them and
since galaxies tend to grow with Time by
merging the Starlight from small
galaxies shouldn't be far brighter than
any Galaxy today there's only one way to
generate the vast amounts of energy a
quasar shines with feeding supermassive
black holes we still don't know how
exactly they formed but it seems that
every galaxy has one in their Center but
how can the brightest things in the
universe beat black holes which trap
anything and everything that crosses
their Event Horizon well the light of a
quasar is not coming from inside these
black holes rather it comes from the
space around them a massive orbiting
disc of gas called an attrition desk
quasars use the same fuel as stars to
shine matter it's just that black holes
are the most efficient engines for
converting matter into energy in the
universe
the energy released by matter falling
into a black hole can be 60 times
greater than that released by nuclear
fusion in the core of a star because the
energy released by a black hole comes
from Gravity not from nuclear reactions
matter falling into a black hole speeds
up to almost the speed of light before
it crosses the Event Horizon buzzing
with an incredible amount of kinetic
energy
of course once inside the black hole it
takes that energy with it
you only get to witness this energy if
you drop your matter in the right way
fall straight down and the outside
Universe gets nothing but when you have
a lot of matter it spirals in incredibly
fast towards the Event Horizon following
a disc
collisions between particles and
friction heated up to hundreds of
thousands of degrees
in a space not much bigger than our soda
system the core of a Galaxy can release
many times more energy than all its
Stars combined
this is what a quasar is a supermassive
black hole having a feast and these
black holes eat a lot typical quasars
consume 1 to 100 Earth masses of gas per
minute
10 billion years ago the universe was
about a third of its current size so the
intergalactic medium was much less
spread out meaning the filaments of gas
around quasars could feed them a banquet
making them vomit insane amounts of
light and radiation
the brightest quasars power jet tangling
the magnetic field of the matter around
them into a narrow cone
like a particle accelerator they launch
enormous beams of matter out plowing
through the circumgalactic medium
forming plumes of matter that grow to
hundreds of thousands of light years in
size it's almost unfathomable in scale a
tiny spot in a galaxy carving out
patches of the universe hundreds of
thousands of light years long
but quasars can't eat for long maybe a
few million years because their feast
ultimately kills their Galaxy
how quasars kill galaxies
okay maybe killing is a bit of an
exaggeration a galaxy is still there
after its Quasar turns off but it will
never be the same again
quasars being among the hottest and the
brightest things in the universe break
their galaxies by heating them up too
much and stopping star formation stars
are gas that collapsed in on itself and
they got really hot but in a cloud of
gas that's already hot atoms are moving
quickly when they Collide they hit hard
exerting pressure that resists gravity's
squeeze so hot gas cannot form Stars
instead the best gas for forming stars
is already cold and won't put up a fight
when it's time to collapse into a star
on top of that quasars push gas out of
their galaxies not only does this starve
the Quasar but its Galaxy loses the raw
materials for new stars
as sad as this sounds it might be a good
thing for Life the alternative can be
far more dangerous too many stars new
stars forming is usually followed by
massive stars exploding in supernovae so
planets would be burned sterile
but of course it's more complicated
like the intricacies of our own planets
biosphere every piece of the Galaxy is
dependent on and influencing every other
part of the galactic environment while
hot things like quasars and supernovae
tend to push gas out of the Galaxy shock
waves and Quasar Jets can also compress
gas making new stars at least for a
short time but in general we can say
that without things becoming a bit more
chill we would not exist today which
brings us to our final question did the
Milky Way have a quasar in the past it's
unclear if every Galaxy went through a
quasar phase but understanding distant
quasars May provide clues to the history
of the Milky Way galaxies don't do a
good job of preserving their history
like sand on a beach the endless
churning mixes away the clues to their
past
it's possible the Milky Way was once a
quasar which may have allowed our
supermassive black hole Sagittarius A
star to have grown to four million times
the mass of the Sun and as dormant as it
is now Sagittarius A star could turn
into a quasar in the future in a few
billion years the Milky Way will merge
with Andromeda we've seen over a hundred
double quasars in galaxies smashing
together where fresh gas is provided for
the central black holes
but it won't last for long when galaxies
merge so do their supermassive black
holes sinking into the center of their
new Galaxy kicking up dust and stars in
every direction we don't know whether
this will happen but it would truly be
an incredible sight maybe some beings in
the far future are going to witness it
and be in awe of what they see
but you don't have to wait that long
there are already plenty of fascinating
things to explore right here on this
planet right now if you have the
knowledge to understand them to help you
with that we've created a series of
lessons to take your scientific
knowledge to the next level made in
collaboration with our friends at
brilliant.org these lessons give you a
deeper understanding of the topics from
our most popular videos from rabies and
mammalian metabolism to climate science
there's also a lesson on black holes
where you can delve into the fundamental
principles behind their formation and
behavior a deeper understanding will
also help you appreciate their role in
powering the quasars we talked about in
this video brilliant is an Interactive
Learning tool that makes maths science
and computer science accessible with a
Hands-On approach because we know that
to really learn something you've got to
do it think of each lesson as a
one-on-one tutoring version of a quartz
gazard video brilliant has thousands of
other lessons to explore as well
from maths-based topics like algebra and
probability to courses around
programming and data science
their latest course how technology Works
takes you inside the technology you use
every day your walk in the footsteps of
a hacker to discover why some passwords
take decades to crack explore how
satellites and space know that your
Rideshare driver is just down the street
learn why your favorite quotes art video
might buffer on YouTube and more to get
Hands-On with kotzuk's lessons and
explore everything brilliant has to
offer you can start your free 30-day
trial by signing up at brilliant.org
nutshell there's even an extra perk for
kotskazart viewers the first 200 people
to use the link get 20 off an annual
membership once their trial ends we love
seeing how the gears interlock with our
research brilliant gives you the tools
to understand how everything fits
together
we know you've been waiting for a long
time let's reveal the next limited
edition pen it's the Dyson Sphere this
very special pin set represents our
Dream for the future of humanity charge
it with energy from the Sun and it will
glow in the dark pre-order is available
for only 72 hours so order now before
time runs out the next limited edition
pin will be revealed soon
when
[Music]
foreign